it is the final showdown it's
practically a must eat during football
games talking nachos chef bruce kalman
throwing down his version of the fan
favorite for some big game grub
okay back again it is the final recipe
day chef bruce you've got the best one
my favorite nachos
you gotta have the build your own nacho
bar you know and
as we talked before like you know go
crazy figure out what things you love
and go find those things and put them on
top of tortilla chips and you got nachos
right it makes it so easy i love that
you kind of you know have a little bit
of everything for somebody we've got
some pickled you know pickled red onions
some escobich we've got some cilantro
scallions cheddar cheese
fresh jalapenos some cut smoked bacon
there's a little bit of our pulled pork
our brisket
uh some guacamole
some ranch some texas ranch beans we do
that's how we kind of do our nachos
some cheese sauce that we make here as
well and pico de gallo it sounds perfect
so have at it okay so i want to see what
you're going to come up with all right
so we're starting with the
[Applause]
with the tips here
good all right
now is the key you have to kind of layer
as you go yeah okay my thing is like i
hate when you get nachos and like you
get to the bottom of the thing and it's
there's nothing wrong with dry chips
right so i would always start with sauce
okay all right so sauce unless you're
melting cheese on but
and uh can you ever have too much cheese
what do you think so now you can buy
this obviously you can make it or you
can come here and pick it up get it yeah
that makes it easy right we try to make
it easy for you some beans beans yeah
there we go now these you said are your
they call it yeah they're texas ranch
beans it's a barbecue bean that we make
it has a lot of meat in it
and some vegetables so a lot of flavor a
lot of flavor and can you buy that here
as well yeah just in case you don't want
to make it absolutely cool all right
jalapenos because i think we need some
spices
these are our pickled onions that we
pickled onions okay so this is gonna
give it just a little bit of a bite huh
exactly oh that looks amazing all right
now uh who's not going to want to eat
that so nachos nachos for the win yeah
[Applause]